una concentración en lagos nigeria de
género rápidamente en un caos mientras
el sonido de los disparos colmaba el
aire según varios testigos cientos de
personas se estaban reuniendo en el
distrito de laki cuando los soldados
comenzaron a disparar munición real
alrededor de las siete de la noche hora
local las protestas contra la brutalidad
policial continuaron a pesar del toque
de queda de 24 horas más tarde esa noche
el gobernador de la ciudad tuiteó fotos
de él visitando a las víctimas de lo que
denominó un desafortunado incidente de
tiroteo añadiendo que unas 25 personas
estaban siendo tratadas por sus heridas
el gobierno afirma que no había tropas
presentes en el lugar del tiroteo sin
embargo amnistía internacional dice que
tiene pruebas creíbles de que varias
personas habían muerto como consecuencia
de los disparos de las fuerzas de
seguridad los nigerianos han salido a la
calle todos los días desde principios de
octubre para denunciar la brutalidad
policial tras las revelaciones de
persecución asesinato y tortura a manos
de una unidad especial de la policía
desde entonces la brigada
contra el robo se ha disuelto pero en
las protestas se han transformado en un
movimiento antigubernamental más amplio
decían que nigeria sería mejor pero
hasta ahora estamos sufriendo así que
queremos luchar por nuestros derechos en
la capital abuya las fuerzas de
seguridad han desplegado cañones de agua
y disparado gas lacrimógeno para
dispersar a los manifestantes se han
incendiado coches y edificios el
presidente nigeriano muhammadu buhari ha
prometido reformar la policía pero no ha
logrado resolver el creciente
descontento en el país al menos 15
personas han muerto desde que comenzaron
las protestas hace casi dos semanas